going in
[Applause]
touchdown declared a major success for a
mission
years in the making the spacecraft
dubbed osiris-rex is about the size of a
van
it's been circling the asteroid since
2018 getting ready to make its
precarious landing
oh my gosh um we're there folks that was
amazing i mean i don't know if you saw
the team here but they just kind of blew
up they went from being steely eyed to
like
celebrating the super bowl it's a pretty
amazing technological feat
and and all of this was done by this
probe by itself you know it's too
it's it's far too far away to to be
controlled in
in sort of real time by its handlers
here on earth osiris-rex chose a flat
spot in nightingale crater to touch
down surrounded by boulders as big as
buildings
nasa says the craft kissed the surface
landing for just
five seconds enough to send up a cloud
of dust and rocks
collecting samples scientists hope will
unlock the secrets of life on earth
the spacecraft did everything it was
supposed to do
so we did it we tagged the surface of
the asteroid
and it's up to bennu now to see how the
event went
asteroids like banu date back about 4.5
billion years
so scientists say collecting the samples
is like reaching back in time
asteroids are are terrific and they're
one of the best ways that we have of
learning about the very early history of
the solar system
before the formation of the earth and
moon because after the earth and moon
formed
all the rocks that went into them have
been recycled
japan space agency landed a similar
craft on another asteroid twice
last year its samples due back in
december
the team at nasa has to wait to find out
if osiris-rex picked up enough rubble to
bring back to earth
or it'll have another shot at a landing
seems like things went pretty well today
so we kind of
have our fingers crossed that it worked
and if if they determine that they got
enough then this stuff will be coming
back down to earth hopefully
in september 2023 and scientists will be
able to get their hands on it
these scientists clearly happy with
progress and yet to come back down to
earth
themselves alex o'brien al jazeera